vacation a first-time writer share their
first second even third draft of their
manuscript with family and friends that
is a really interesting question um yes
and no I shared mine with family but not
all family are writers you know and can
give you the kind of feedback you want
but what I did was is I shared it after
it was done because I found telling the
story wasn't that effective they had to
see it done or reading a chapter here
and there wasn't affected they really
didn't know what I was trying to do
unless you want somebody to edit it now
that's different but if you want
feedback on this story they couldn't get
it into the you know they just aren't
there they're not educators educators
tenda are especially english teachers
can look at it and you know kind of give
you some feedback so when it was done
yes I got some feedback and you know
everybody liked it but it's you know
it's good you know but you know will it
sell you know will it get a publisher
and things like that but not much more
than that I just did a little so to
recommend it you're not going to get
what you want but you're going to get
enough to give you some hope or some
ideas of what you need to do so were the
publishers that you submitted to the
first ones to actually see the finished
product or did you get it by any person
that was sort of a confidant that she
trusted okay no I didn't have anybody
look at it except my well my husband but
that was about it but my publisher read
the whole book when it's ready she said
send it to me and I said it's good and
she was very kind and she read it and
she said calls and says I can't put it
down i had to change what i was doing
over the weekend it's really good she I
said I told you it was good she goes no
no everybody says the book is good this
is good
how did you write such a good on book
like oh I don't know I just wrote it um
so then she believed in me and she met
me and she knew I'm serious I'm serious
writer I'm just not writing one book I'm
writing six so we went from there and I
liked her we had a good chemistry and
not from there and I liked her too
because she was one stop shop she's at
five star publishing and her name is
Linda and she's one stop shop and and
nothing goes without my approval but
they have quality work I mean quality
work would you give advice to someone
else on having them look over a first
second or third draft of something what
would you say do exactly what you do
just listen to your own gut about
something because there's that sort of
perception sometimes when someone you
know looks at something and it's sort of
that my grandmother used to say no man's
a profit is own land so sometimes maybe
people look at things differently when
they know you do you think that so much
or they're afraid to say too much or be
critical um and they tend to think that
they need to tell you about editing
instead of revision and see the common
person might think all I got to look at
the periods and the dots and sentences
are wrong and that's not what you really
want you want did you like the
characters did you like this to do like
that you know because you can hire an
editor to fix all that stuff so I think
the answer from my perspective to that
question came to me as an after fact
after the book was out we gave some
advance copies out to some friends and
then I sent some friends some regular
copies and it was really interesting and
from an English teacher's perspective of
what they said not one person out of the
ten people I targeted to send it to I
said tell me what you liked I didn't
want to know what they didn't like it
first and not one person said the same
thing now in answering your question see
I wouldn't get the same from every
person and originally might be think
that is wrong but as an English teacher
teaching literature in high school a
good piece of literature has different
perspectives and that was a is a mark of
a good literature so when I got
something different from each person
then I from my point of view had a good
piece of writing and because one person
said I love wiki you know or I love
amazing or I love the history or I had a
count insane I like the way you write
you know so you got a variety of things
and if you're getting that variety then
you have a decent piece of work
you